want to make your old speakers wireless
without spending Sonos money here are
two cheap options first the $89
gramophone it plugs into your stereo
with an aux cable and connects to the
cloud over Wi-Fi and your friends can
connect instantly without logging in but
if your beats audio or songs the
subscriber think again the gramophone
only works with Spotify for those audio
files with even older analog speakers
the 150 dollar Griffin 20 works like a
time machine for your vintage gear this
20 watt amp will stream music via
bluetooth from your phone or tablet and
its enormous old-school brushed aluminum
volume knob is a nice link to the days
of LPS and mixtapes now you can turn up
that Earth Wind and Fire in style